here's Biden calling out Florida he
doesn't like Florida either because we
are going to stop doctors from giving
young children sex hormone blockers and
we're not going to chop off their
genitals in the old days most of us were
against genital mutilation but here we
are in modern times enjoy transgender
kids is a really harder day thing what's
going on in Florida
is as my mother would say close to
sinful I mean it's just terrible what
they're doing it's not like you know a
kid wakes up one morning and says you
know
I decided I want to become a man or I
want to become a woman or I want to
change I mean what what what are they
thinking about here
they're human beings they love they have
feelings they have inclinations that are
I mean it just to me is
I don't know it's cruel and the way we
do it is we make sure we pass
legislation like we passed on same-sex
marriage you mess with that you're
breaking the law and you're going to be
held accountable yeah sorry you old
buffoon we have something called
federalism and the states are allowed to
make whatever laws they don't like and
then if the citizens don't like those
laws they can leave the states but you
don't get to make some sort of law
that's going to override the state when
it comes to genital mutilation Biden
also he looks horrible like this thing
is just breaking down right in front of
us and he simply has no idea what he's
talking about you know when he says that
it also this is what they do with
everything it all kind of sounds right
kids don't just wake up and say I feel
like a man today or feel like a girl or
whatever that does sort of sound right
except it's wrong because we know there
is a social contagion element to this
thing right we know this for a fact when
they're staring all day long at sex
change operations and boys who are girls
and girls or who are boys and boys with
boobs and chicks with dicks and all of
the stuff right when they do see that
all day long hunted talk we know now
there's a social contagion element to it
Abigail schreier what was Abigail
schreier's book it's a fantastic book uh
irreversible damage thank you she wrote
a fantastic book about this we should
have her on again that young girls in
particular are susceptible to the the
social contagion portion of this meaning
they start seeing these videos and then
they go you know I'm not the girliest
girl ever and actually I like blue more
than I like pink I must be a boy or what
they do the other social contagion
element of of this is they will take a
feminine boy you know I don't even like
that phrase but a boy who maybe isn't
into just cars and and Transformers and
War and whatever
yeah maybe he likes art or something
else and now they will basically say to
him you are actually a girl so it's odd
because they're the ones who are
actually more into gender stereotypes
but the guy has absolutely know what
he's talked no idea what he's talking
about by the way the interviewer there
was Cal Penn who I guess was a comedian
at one time give me his number what was
his movie he did Harold and Kumar went
to White Castle right somehow he's
interviewing Joe Biden I don't know how
that happened
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]